Randy Moss ESPN NFL analyst inducted
into the Vikings Ring of Honor on 9/11
Vikings hosting the Saints Monday Night
Football the 2017 season opener and
Randy joins us now Randy good morning
congratulations how are you good morning
ma'am I appreciate you having me on
what's going on how you doing what do
you make up when you see trash-talking
in the NBA draymond Green and LeBron
James is that really trash-talking and
did you have anything like that in the
NFL that happens every day and is all
around the world I think trash-talking
is good you know as long as you keeping
it you know along along certain lines
knowing that certain things are off
limits but I think it's good for the
sport I think when you look at what
happened in the NBA where goes one one
year Cleveland won last year and goes
they came back and won so two out of
three years they won so I really think
it's good for the NBA to have those
teams are at those stars
you know trash-talking a month one
another still sells more tickets did you
ever do you ever wonder if you'd stayed
with basketball instead of football what
would have happened well there's the guy
by the name of Kevin Garnett and old
high school phenom out of California
named shea cotton that really
discouraged me - well champs of being a
basketball player so it really made my
job easier when I just went from
basketball and decided just to be a
football player so I was undecided in
high school and a junior high school
middle school today but when I met up
with those guys man they made my
decision very easy
wait did you played against Garnett well
we were at camps throughout you know our
childhood and stuff like that so quick
story I told him the story he might not
remember it about there was a rain delay
and we were in Illinois and all the the
games were somewhat canceled because of
the thunderstorm so kevin was out there
shooting 101 I mean he was out there
shooting by itself so I go out there
with him knowing that he was one of the
top guys at the camp so I checked Paul
toting check box fast no banned from
West Virginia was the top athlete from
West Virginia so I tried to take you to
the rim Kevin climbed all the way up on
the backboard above the bank box and
pinned my ball up against the backboard
and I did
we believe the first time I've ever seen
that so throughout the week of the camp
you know these guys are all year-round
basketball players and I was more of a
seasonal athlete so I got discouraged
knowing how good those guys were and it
just made my decision easier to stick
with our football so kg retired you that
day there you go I see the so you get
this on or going into the Ring of Honor
with the Vikings what is there one
moment with the Vikings that stands out
over all the other ones no I really
don't have any any any really moments to
stand out I think that throughout my
tenure there in Minnesota my second
stint there also there was just a lot of
great memories you know just being able
to be in the Metrodome and the biggest
thing for me was a played outside for so
long home you know through high school
even in college so being able to get you
know adjustment to being in the dome
each and every week you know I thought
was really an advantage for us being the
home team so I don't really have any any
you know one memories I just love
playing the game I love being in that
dome and then my favorite team to play
against was Green Bay and competing
against Brett Favre so yes I just take a
lot a lot of members with me why did it
take a little while to get adjusted to
the dome and why was that an advantage
for you well I think I really think that
you know being outdoors you know you
really got it you've been playing I've
been playing outdoors since you know Pop
Warner [ __ ] League so I've always been
used to you know the Sun and you don't
really get a lot of night games and if
you get a lot of night games you got to
get used to lights and things like that
no matter day night in the dome you got
to get used to the lights regardless so
a lot of the the adjustments that I had
to make definitely like my rookie year
is like going into the dome for
afternoon games going after getting
adjusted to the lighting but then second
second of all being able to have the
fans and that noise going up and coming
back down to the ground so I think
there's been some games where you know
I'm standing right next to one of my
teammates and could not hear you know
what we were talking about just because
the excitement of the game so I think
that in domes like
when you really feel the energy coming
from the fans how about that with an
advantage that we really took advantage
of at times who would be the quarterback
you'd want to catch one more pounds from
one more pass from roof ah I'd have to
go around with my boy Tom and I'd have
to say Tom I think that you know there's
a lot of quarterbacks that I did have
success with I had some great times with
cold pepper I loved playing with Jeff
George the love playing with Gus Marat
love playing with Tom Brady but just
being able to catch one more pass man I
would love to catch one for Tom but the
quarterbacks that I just named man we're
good quarterbacks we understood one
another and I always liked the
quarterback they can just get it to me
you know don't put a lot of floating in
the air a lot of balloon balls I don't
like that get me the ball so I can make
something happen and those guys that I
name were able to get me the ball make
it happen but if you actually one more
pass and I'm going with 12 12 give me
one more
give me a Tom Brady's story I haven't
heard oh man a Tom Brady story you
haven't heard ah well I really don't
really have any really think that video
yelling now never never never yelled at
me this one funny story is the year that
he got heard this is one of my probably
the best memories that I'll take from
being up there playing with the Patriots
was we play Kansas City and Tom ended up
tearing his knee on the play threw the
ball to me I was having back spasms that
day so I wasn't really even supposed to
play that game sucked it up we wanna
play he got hurt on the play they threw
the ball of he threw the ball to me I
laid down gingerly on the ground because
I didn't want to get hit because my back
was messed up I fumbled the ball okay so
the following week you know they talk
about Tom could possibly be out for the
season
you know everybody has their fingers
crossed the media's right and everything
that's going on so I come in
I can't forget what part of the week it
was but I was one of the first guys in
Tom's in there throwing wooden e brace
up he's in there throwing with a knee
brace on so I'm kind of looked puzzled
like did you talk about you're gonna our
for the year no I'm not going imma try
to play this week so he's telling me
he's trying to play I immediately put my
stuff down at the locker and go in the
locker room and start catching the balls
that he would throw he was doing in the
locker room was just me and him and I
think Jim Leyland the trainer of them
trying to get over Dave Dave Granito
trying to get him back and so everybody
didn't know that tom was willing ready
to go out and play the following week
with a knee brace no he just towards me
so I think that he was sacrificing
knowing that we just come off of 18 in
one season and the following season he
got hurt and he felt so bad he didn't
want to let the team down so that's one
of my memories from him and coming in
that locker room knowing that everybody
said that he's going to be on IR but he
still was in there trying to throw and
plan on that leg to try to get out there
and see if he can still play what was
that like though that moment where you
realized you were going undefeated and
you lose that soup you're going to lose
that Super Bowl like what are you
thinking at the time because you guys
had to thank you guys were invincible
there you go it was that painful yep yep
actually net you just hung up on still
can't and I can't disrupt it cellphones
just can't talk about it right now how
the questions do you think Belichick is
they're just he's got some button that
he can press if you're gonna say
something about the Patriots something
that could be revealing that all of a
sudden like click let's go back to that
Kevin Garnett story Randy pretty it's
okay if he when she's trying to call him
back there
yeah but I'm looking at these numbers I
didn't know that he ended up with less
than a thousand catches it doesn't feel
like that
he ended up 18 reception shy of 1,000 in
his career did you hang up on me without
a tough question for you to answer there
Randy I think I was get it here too
but what was that feeling like you guys
were invincible you're undefeated and at
what point in that game did you go we're
in trouble here I think when Eli Manning
got rushed Eli Manning threw just threw
a ball to the sidelines just threw it
over there there was no receiver over
there Asante Samuels
ran the route for two receiver I can't
remember who the receiver was but only
thing assigned he had to do was catch
the ball get his two feet in Super Bowl
champions he missed the ball so after
knowing what type of athlete that he is
one of the best athletes on the team
that year all-around athlete for him to
be able to miss that ball no defect old
receiver was owning it was just him in
the ball get you two feet down he missed
the ball when he missed that ball
knowing that was that was it like a
routine interception that's when I knew
we were in trouble that's like a minute
20 minute 30 left I think in the in the
fourth quarter there but it's David
Tyree on the pattern I'm seeing it here
yeah that's got to be crushing he
catches it that's it it's over when he
caught the ball you know his fans were
still for crazy and you know I don't
know what type of feeling I had but I
know we still had time so Tom comes in
the hole in the huddle come on guys we
still got time we got time so I think we
ran a play I can't remember the results
then we came back and he said we were
running a over route like three deep
sand that was going on me on the over so
I'm on the backside by myself
Tom's tells me Randy runs it over and as
soon as I look back at you you'll be
line and take it back high angle to the
corner excuse me so when Tom looks at me
I take all beeline it and still to this
day my fingers touched that ball and I
missed the ball I was tired and you know
still to this day I still sit there
wonder what can I have done different to
be
to try and catch that ball my specialty
was going deep we got two guys on you
Randy I'm looking at it it's at the
10-yard line you got two guys on you I
mean I still think I can come up with
all 15 so it was just one feature just
want to make a play and uh the crazy
part about it was it took me about two
to three weeks ranted to get over the
soreness from that game I had ran a lot
probably the most I've ever ran in my
whole career so when he when he threw me
the ball back and looked back at me and
threw it back hangul to the to the pylon
I really thought that was it that we
could you know I could have caught that
ball we could have connected but I
missed it I got a couple fingertips on
it and it was just like wow man we we
came up short so just all the way up to
the to the last play of the game
really still thought we had a chance
regardless of the David Tyree kiss
regardless of Asante Samuels missing you
know the interception so with all the
bad stuff that went on throughout the
game we still had a shot at the end of
the game and you know we broke records
we got all these accolades so they put
it in been Tom's hanoar we took it upon
ourselves we just didn't make it happen
here you're going to be talking about
all the great things you've accomplished
the Ring of Honor and I'm bringing up
these negative things there that's
mean-spirited me Randy that's merited by
the way you you made the transition to
TV and it's not as easy as you're making
it look you're doing a great job with
that have you had that moment where you
say something about somebody that you
get they respond back to you like what
are you doing man like you know how can
you do that to me have you had one of
those moments yet no I try I really take
pride and when I say I really really
take pride in not trying to do that I
think what if there is a guy out there
just just put a bad football on the
field or there coach just click bad
coaching on the field then of course
they're going to get called out but I
think that everything that I've
experienced from people just trying to
sell papers or people just trying to get
a story or some recognition I've been
through a lot of that throughout the
course of my career so I know I know
what it feels like so for me to be able
to do that too
mother man I'm trying my best to stay
away from that I don't I don't want to
be that type of analyst I really don't
well congrats on the Ring of Honor and
next time you're on we'll just talk
about all the positive things that you
did in your career not not to lose in
the superclass it's alright man it comes
with the territory my joy at a time I
appreciate you Thank You Randy
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience